the high cost of medical care is giving
some Americans sticker shock annual
health care spending in the u.s. is
estimated to be three and a half
trillion dollars hospital costs make up
almost 1/3 of that total kaiser Health
News in partnership with National Public
Radio uncovers inconsistencies in its
bill of the month series in this month
that series takes a look at drew Calvert
he was hospitalized last year in Austin
Texas for a heart attack and needed four
stents and his arteries he has health
insurance through his teaching job and
the insurance covered fifty-five
thousand dollars of the bill but a month
after treatment he and his wife Erin got
a bill for nearly one hundred and nine
thousand dollars early May I got the
first bill alright that's not right two
weeks later yes till I get another bill
and this routine that just got
exhausting every two weeks I'm getting
my folder out looking up the numbers
getting my got my old notebook he would
call and then I would just stress him
out and then we're getting you know
bills in the mail and it you know it's
not adding up to us and we're just
confused and we're frustrated Ida
supplies my focus should be staying
healthy and preventing another heart
attack you do all this to save this
person's lives and then you're making
their lives like a living nightmare
exactly is what the a lot of people say
about that kaiser Health News and CBS
News contacted the hospital it's st.
David's Medical Center so they told
Calvary that he may qualify for a
financial assistance discount what could
bring his bill down to an estimated
lessness 782 dollars the hospital says
that it offered Calvary the opportunity
to apply for financial assistance
several times and that the charges
reflect the retail price for a procedure
treatment or visit dr. Elizabeth
Rosenthal's editor-in-chief of kaiser
Health News and joins us at the table
really to sort this out because it
sounds like they got some splaining to
do so he gets a bill of 109 thousand
dollars and it can be negotiated down to
seven hundred something how is that even
possible
well the price of that hospital charge
the hospital's charge a kind of
arbitrary they can be anything they can
remove it out of where Elizabeth where
do they get it from in their eye
say I looked at this bill and the prices
for everything every line item we're
just exorbitant $200 for a blood test
$20,000 for one single stent I mean who
knows we've looked into that those fence
probably cost a thousand dollars so
there's markup on everything but who
knew you could negotiate I'm used to
saying is this the best price I didn't
know you could do that with your
hospital bill well this is my first
piece of advice to people don't write
the check that you have some agency you
have some powers so the first thing is
you get the itemized bill because who
would paint it for anything that you
didn't when you didn't know even what
you were paying for then go in you can
negotiate and here are some tools you
can use you can look on health care blue
book you can look at what Medicare pays
and you can go in and say to someone
who's trying to charge you a hundred
thousand dollars this is ridiculous this
is way above the norm and the funny
thing is hospitals expect this and
sometimes will respond I don't
understand why his insurance didn't
cover it well this is the odd thing
we're talking about a hundred thousand
dollar-plus built after insurance his
insurance paid the hospital fifty five
thousand dollars already so what we have
here which is a really common situation
in American medicine is the hospital and
the insurer disagree on a price and the
patient gets left holding the bag for
the divet to clarify the hospital was an
out-of-network provider but they told
him they would cover it because it was
an emergency
aren't to dump these deductibles in your
health insurance too once you meet a
certain deductible don't they cover
above and beyond that no this is he got
caught in a trap there's this as you
said they're out of theirs out of
network care but in an emergency any
hospital whether it's out of network or
not has to ask to give you care but what
happens when it's out of network is your
normal insurance protections don't apply
so that's called surprise billing that
gap that they can go after you for it is
a surprise bill now many states 21
states now have surprise billing laws
that mean two in part hold the the
patient harmless in the case of
something like this but they don't work
very well as drew found out his insurer
paid fifty five thousand and then he was
hit with a hundred and ten thousand
dollar bill it's
really outrageous so is this an acute
case that's special with special facts
or is could this happen to anybody based
on what you just did this could happen
to anybody and we get literally
thousands of bills so this does happen
to everybody it may not be at a hundred
thousand dollars you know this is kind
of an extreme amount of money but in
smaller amounts ten thousand twenty
thousand it happens all the time well
just the fact that you call it bill of
the Month series says to me that there's
an issue here I'm just stunned to know
that we can negotiate that way yes
that's good to know you should know you
can negotiate you should check what the
laws are in your state and with your
health plan to find out what protections
you have and you should always always
always fight back I think that's the
message right back don't don't just
write the check you're simultaneously
trying to fight back against whatever
the oh well that's that's the real
sickness right then when you should be
focusing on your heart attack and
recovery you're instead stress that
about your credit rating and not her
another those bills are hard to read -
thank you that's also a problem yeah
hard to read yeah dr. Elizabeth
Rosenthal thank you so much